ragazzi non fate come sa challenge a
causa ciao a tutti la nuova challenge
sembra gravissimo richieste sempre con
vitale di giocatori che da sempre il
video andiamo parla challenger del
gabinetto in faccia se ne vi ricordate
del video precedente dello shopping
della sua amazzonia ho ricevuto questo
buono cattivo gioco che non vedevo l'ora
di provare ma non renderemo un pochino
che si perchè sennò mettendo solo acqua
dentro che questo certo meglio renderlo
un ruolo ancora aperto quindi andiamo ad
aprirlo chiediamo uno sforzo e come sono
le regole del gioco come funziona la
grande attenzione abbiamo pure la carta
igienica chi si è inventato questo gioco
è come gli eventi e momenti
soprattutto perché se richiesto
l'assemblaggio da parte di un adulto
vedo l'ora che troverai architetto
impazza
in queste persone chi vincerà secondo
voi tra vedono le richieste per fortuna
queste cose allora indovinate chi è
riuscita a montarlo poi il nostro
gabinetto
in pratica dovremo girare la carta
igienica e dice quante volte devi tirare
lo sciacquone tiferemo ritirarlo perciò
vi propongono per tacco ma spero di non
macchiare la maglietta va bene acqua
e poi se sentiamo il rumore dello sapone
vuol dire che è andato tutto bene
altrimenti che mi sembra che non si
notano magari muore croce anche studioso
tutto ok ora andiamo a riempirlo cosa
andiamo a fare devo mettere la bomba
no vabbè ma ci sporchiamo
il nuovo potenti perché questi sono
coloranti 1 e giallo a me sembra
arancione o nel giallo in scacco la rea
avorio mallorio quindi faranno un bel
marroncino nello stand tifosi no e poi
il cibo per tornare andiamo a mettere
dei pezzettini di aglio così costerà
pure numeri a chi capita in faccia
questa ci aspetta sarà una vera e
propria punizione mita acqua normale
ancona che malissimo e io vado a noi
collegati nova t no si poteva trovare i
bianchi esportano
lo sa bene che questo è potente ma sarà
stasera incollati riordino per uno stato
con la colla
forse è meglio se lo salutiamo però
sotto dio non vi dico che fa sembrare
finto era miglia nette ora dobbiamo
semplicemente mettere dei pezzetti di
biennio infettivi ajo già puzzo da qui
che agita non poco dir colorate prende
meglio il colore da tempo che i nuovi
l'ho un po perché non con orari si sono
un pezzo di ag galleggianti e poi con la
cosa nera in realtà è il colorante solo
che non so perché ma è rimasto solido
chi riceverà questa schifezza in faccia
di chi sarà il fortunato impronta gori
abbiamo mischiato un po meglio il
colorante guardate un po che galleggia
tutti
e quindi devo solo girare questo devo
girare i numeretti em all origine di dei
numeretti per fargli vedere la 3 non
avere 13 da poco quindi che un andato
due è andata male
ok ragazzi tocca a me allora giriamo la
carta igienica 32 guardo la dea adesso
si è spostato 3
[Musica]
il primo sconfitto interessato conti ma
un occhio solo vendetta perché questa è
continua
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no non ho fatto perché sbaglio perché ti
capiti subito infatti anche te numero
uno
kami controllare se non mi chiedo allora
volontà di mettere cosa dico io ero
vicinissima perché c'è il caso league
non solo per quello che non si vede
molto perché lo spruzzo disco
supersottile sviluppo che avvicinandosi
scrivere meglio forza se non avete
ancora fatto
avvicinati faccio io vicina di più
mamma mia scusate istinto dentro prima
vicina tanto nei premi finché adulti e
piccini si 612 d'aula la clientela nulla
via che potenza che non era uno fai
vedere che 1
mettiti bene libero schermo toccate le
forme tra david e mercy una vizzino
prima prevede remi alla prossima
verifica con la testa dentro né vendere
bene ne stava profondità robinho che mi
fa paura
dai bastard ex bari ritiro no estraggo
devi rifare
a parte che minano 3 farà male è una
strega faccio io avvicina di amici nati
mamma turisti incidendo aggiunti poi
avvicinato avvicina di uno
inter ti sta bene
tutto bello zaia perché me1 sempre 10
vicine di burke i ragazzi dai un
bastardo con bersani no giro va bene non
due come due ragazzi di atzori dio
vicina che cos'è
[Musica]
toccate dai ben tre adesso uno
avvicinati bene mi raccomando un brutto
presentimento faccio io credo amici
vedevo vicina di destra vicino capito
che devo chiamare così si vede ad essere
schizzano una mano da eroe dai
avvicinati ricevere dopo lo voglio
rivedere o vedere tutte le volte che mi
ha spinto dentro credo scrivetelo nei
commenti anche perché arriva una fifona
finché fruttate non finiamo il gioco che
è uno stato pubblica
tale possibile perché sul mondo ma non
mi dire in merito
bene sempre tu non ti mette
[Applauso]
[Musica]
puzza ma l'ho detto anche ai ragazzi
siccome abbiamo già ricevuto il rigetto
del terrificante
abbiamo deciso di aggiungere una cosa
tante realtà di come nonostante abbiamo
messo il colorante il 7 abbastanza
trasparente con questo non vedrete
ancora meglio e penso che si macchierà
la faccia un po prima campo in faccia
quindi andiamo commettere più per
colorante e vediamo subito come diventa
allora vediamo qualche concetto nuovo
sull'ora mettiamone un bel po troppo
costose questo colorante rimane solido
tipo fi mischia fatto nessun addio
che schifo fa schifo perché rimane così
solido
[Musica]
oh mio dio mio dio che schifo è
diventata marrone con i pezzettini
sei pronto adesso è ancora più contento
di fare k challenge
[Risate]
questa volta sarà ancora peggio voi
avrete il coraggio di forza sociale
anche con quest'acqua schifosissima il
mondo mercoledì tondo deng fra le 1
aiuto nodo avvicinati ti puoi avvicinare
[Musica]
mamma mi hanno offerto dai sia più
vicina la tiro io così te lo faccio
vedere chi è salvezza
cercate toccate gira time beltre adesso
invece no così pure girato meglio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
avvicinate ti vai a avvicinare vicina di
piscina di scena il prossimo 29 ma mira
e di un color limpida la cosa la diva
dagli occhi dall'odore di agno
fortissimo 22 aiuto io lo faccio io a
mitigati
[Musica]
del naso previsto per salvarci potrebbe
aperto due ragazzi siamo messi malissimo
scusate ragazzi non fate questa
challenge a casa guardati gli occhi non
fate questa sala con l'aglio a casa
perché potreste farvi molto male non
fatelo a casa o michael oggi io non lo
fate a casa ok se lo fate questo
fortemente il colorante ma non riesce il
tenaglia nella sua te online di conforto
per ios 5 con un gene a gissi mila live
st andremo a fare un'altra gialle con la
cipolla malefico tutti gli anni si pure
quali altre challenge e potremmo fare
con questo bambinetto quindi cosa potevo
metterci dentro io e le fa volevo
mettere dentro lo slime non funziona
perché non lo prende dai tubi fini ha
scritto anche voi nei commenti degli atc
pure che altre sale giocare assieme
scrivete istituzioni in commenti e
sapere quando e stata la parte più
divertente il secondo voi lasciate il
time stamp sotto 0 0 2 punti 22 punti 34
così poi vado a rivedermi le parti più
divertiti e reader touch o mio dio
che ha fatto male gli occhi no solo un
po di fastidio quando mettono il naso
l'ultima volta
adesso mi dà un po di prurito
ma perche sia condizionato sto bene
tutte nei commenti mi raccomando un bel
like e vi lasciamo ora qua 4 candeline
su cui potete cliccare per vedere le
mostre altre alle imprese nonché
preferite ma l'avanzata lavarti non è
l'ideale
ciao a tutti